all right tugboat
yeah Tugboat uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
uh Orange County
um
like Yorba Linda area and then down by
the beach
uh Newport area what was your family
like
it's cool uh
uh single mom
I love her she's
does everything for me
even more than she should
and uh she left my dad and I was one
years old because he uh
like abused her
tried to kill her
uh
how would you describe your childhood in
general
it was
better than a lot of other kids
money
was not really an issue
my mom worked all the time
she may not have been there all the time
but
she did what she had to do so I had a
good life up until I
was about
13 and started rebelling really bad
you finish High School
I actually got my GED when I was 16 in
juvenile hall so you went to I was in
general prison instead of finishing
school yeah I was there for 11 months uh
for a string of uh burglaries and
robbery
yeah
you think not having your dad in your
your life was uh
the reason you kind of took that
Direction
yeah it was also the fact that my dad
my mom told me that my she married my
dad in Chino State Prison
back in like 1980 or something like that
and uh
uh
man yeah he was in for murder him and a
bunch of buddies uh dropped a concrete
block on some dude's head over in Long
Beach back in the late 70s and
he had a manslaughter and she ended up
marrying him
I guess her dad didn't want her to but
he ended up
I think going to the wedding on the
Chino East yard
in prison and I ended up on the same
yard as him where they got married and
she visited me there that's the first
time she was there in like
[__] 25 years
we all have 30 probably over that 30
years since she had been there and it
was kind of weird
I think I don't know
but
so when you got out and you were free
what kind of what'd you get into
um
so at the beginning of like my shake a
criminal career it was a
I was involved in a skinhead gang
um
I
you know would uh
after I got into that gang you know I
had to do some uh
things that are uh
yeah uh pretty bad to get in there you
know it wasn't like uh the other gangs
like the Mexican gangs the black games
you get like jumped in you have to
actually go do like
like a shooting or something you know
something uh of a random
Person Of A different race
you know and uh
this is in prison
no this was on the street yeah
and
um
you know it was whatever so we had to
witness it and uh
it was
kind of stupid looking back on it now
like having somebody witness a crime
like that you know
but
uh I you know did what I did and then I
went to prison
for uh
like burglaries mostly uh even though
what I did a lot of was sell drugs back
then and uh
robberies and stuff but most of them are
like drug dealers I would Rob or people
that I know would have money like in
their houses and stuff you know like a
lot of foreigners have shoe boxes full
of money in their closets because they
don't believe in bank accounts
so
yeah just a lot of that uh
I was always a interest in tattooing too
so I started tattooing a lot
uh but that really started like after I
went to prison for the first time but
I've done like 14 years the last one I
did was uh I got nine years with 85.
for a violent residential burglary
which
the United side it really wasn't even
violent at all
it's really stupid how it went down I
literally broke into a car
you know parking structure
and they ended up giving it to me
because there was a potential for me
going upstairs
and hurting people but it
all I did was bring it to a car and they
gave me nine years for it but that's I'm
grateful for that
very grateful for that because I
actually stayed clean the whole time I
was busted and
didn't stay you know uh clean off of
drugs I I was I actually had dropped out
uh because they gave me uh my second
strike I didn't want to
um
uh stain for a long time you know
because I have potential for the gang
that I was in to uh have to do you know
put in work you know stabbing people and
I've done all the all that I mean like
when I was active and I just didn't want
to do that this time but uh I mean there
was there was one time in this
this last term that I did at a
a prison up north where they started
releasing a bunch of lifers and stuff
and granting people parole
that uh had been in for like heinous
stuff like child molesters man
and they gave this one dude
uh
who was in there for uh three three
counts of uh lewd acts on a minor two of
them were under the age of eight the
other one was under the age of 14.
and uh prolonged abuse of a child of a
family member you know and uh
I went to go say something to him and as
I picked up the People magazine that was
on his table in the day room his table
he like
he sat there for the year and a half I
was there on that yard
uh I picked it up and I went as I went
to go say something to him I opened it
and he had made his own
like kitty porn man like he would take
the pornography of like women in these
magazines that would have like you know
no no no no boobs flat chested and and
had a
like no pubic hair and he would put
pictures of the kids faces over the uh
the faces of the models and he would
make he made his own little child thing
and as I
as I I grabbed it I and I looked at it
he realized that he was he was [__]
man
and I told him to sit there and I waited
for chow to start
after I showed my celly my celly told me
what are you going to do man my celly
was an l-wop
life without parole see there's no
chance of getting out and I told him I'm
gonna kill that dude man he's gonna get
out there and touch kids dude ruin kids
lives man
and uh he said all right man I got you
back
so as they opened up all three sides of
the 270 building I was on Seaside and he
was our neighbor he had just actually
moved there like a week before
uh
uh the door the door's open they were
not supposed to open all three sections
at a time but the cop there was lazy you
know so he went like ABC and it opened
up all three sections top and bottoms
here and as he looked over at the a side
because the other cops were in the chow
hall
I went in with the ice pick
and I kicked him back onto the table in
the back of the cell and I stabbed him
28 times in the head
with ice pick
you know I went into this other cell and
I
gave the shirt to my celly and I went to
Chow put another shirt on and
four hours passed
and uh
uh since since it happened and nobody
had seen it in an account and they had
found him
so they didn't local checks on everyone
and you know got the detectives or
whatever ISU in there and they uh
they uh
had been told by like somebody in
another cell you know that uh the people
when one
143 or 142 whatever cell I was in I
forget but
um that one of them did it so as they
called me out and I sell it out they put
us both in cages
and basically told me to shut up in
front of him and they said uh Mr so and
so my you know my my celly at the time
who was actually in there for killing
his parents
um
back in the 90s or whatever right and
it's not that Menendez brothers either
but uh just some nerd kid that killed
his parents man
when he was 19 and he uh
they told me they said uh
hey uh
keep your mouth shut basically call me
by my name and uh looked at my silly and
said hey man we know we know what
happened here are you gonna say what
happened here like we're gonna tell you
how to say what happened here
I'm looking at my selling he's looking
at me he's like uh what happened
he said uh
he came at you and you you stabbed him
right I mean you had you he had a knife
right
he said you're ill-wop
uh it's just mutual combat with a with a
with a death attached to it uh we'll get
you six months in the shoe but we'll
we'll uh
we'll give you a uh
I don't know what the word is like a uh
a stay
of a non-stave execution but you know
like
um
uh all you have to do is a week and
they'll give you like a suspended
sentence of the shoe right so what
you're saying is the correctional
officer is kind of yeah
they knew I mean this dude they were
pissed that he was going home too I mean
I worked as a as a as a uh in the in the
clerk's office you know sex offenders
just have it so rough yeah there's I
mean [__] scum man
yeah I have three kids man I don't they
don't have a chance
fellow inmates to the to the
correctional officers they're doomed no
actually you know what they get treated
better than most other inmates in there
they do yeah by the cops because they're
they're afraid of lawsuits and stuff oh
I see yeah it's sick
it's really sick
but yeah so you know that that was just
one incident you know he ended up coming
back to the yard like a week later and
we were selling again for about six four
months and then I dropped down
uh another level
and uh they told me uh
they said um
you know uh uh we're gonna send you to a
program your last five months here
uh but the program's on the streets so I
ended up doing a program but the whole
time I had stayed to clean off the drugs
right
and uh I wanted to become a
a drug counselor
and um I ended up uh
doing that when I got out for a little
bit I got married
to a girl that I met 16 years before on
the internet back in Myspace was a thing
and uh after a month of talking we got
married I moved her out here
and um
she helped getting cancer
and uh
she wanted to spend the rest of her life
for the love of her life and that wasn't
me it was Rex
uh but that was all right I Know What
Love Is Love Is Love
I have a strong love for my baby mama
she's we both done prison terms for each
other
uh she's just as gangster as I am
sometimes more
and uh
she's actually one of the reasons why I
had to drop out because I have kids of
mixed race
and uh I got shot for that and stabbed
by my own
um comrades you know
but
I never told on on anyone about anything
like that and uh I just went off right
when I got to prison just went straight
to the yard so I didn't have to uh
tell anybody or roll it up from in your
yard because if you're on an active yard
and you go to drop out you have to like
debrief you have to tell everybody
what they did or you have to tell on a
crime in there to get out of there
yeah
but yeah so she she sorry I'm jumping
everywhere but she ended up moving
back to the east coast and went with her
ex-boyfriend that she loved so much that
she's fighting her cancer but he ended
up leaving her for his baby mama
because you know karma's a [__]
but
I still talk to her
we're still married
she's still fighting the cancer
she actually uh she had gone to kidney
transplant before the cancer that's why
she got the cancer is because of her
anti-rejection pills
and uh she ended up
[Music]
getting a rare or some crazy bone cancer
that went from like the size of a peed
to the size of like a softball on her
rib in like a month
it was crazy
but I ended up relapsing this is after I
was a drug counselor for
a year a little over a year and I I had
worked in
rehab down here in uh
in uh by Skid Row around here right
around here
and uh
I ended up starting getting high while I
was working there
and uh and it was just I I told myself I
wasn't going to be doing anything I was
doing before
and
I wasn't really doing anything like that
and then I started doing stuff like that
and I met uh
I met a lone shark and a couple of
dealers and I told him hey man I could
do some collections you know they're
like yeah you really about that life you
know I'm like just give me someone
and uh one of the lone sharks gave me a
uh 150 let's say case right 150 cases I
took on right I get paid half of
whatever the uh the amount is right that
they get owed so and sometimes there's a
few drug dealers that would be like hey
here's just take it all man just just go
just go get where it's supposed to be
right
or what's supposed to be paid so uh this
loan shark gives me 150 case my first
one
and uh
I had this uh South African
um
dude that I had met
uh
column uh
Fabian
and uh
little dark skin you know black guy from
South Africa you know we look like a
weird
Duo you know a weird team but it worked
and he listened and I told him you want
to make money
come with me he had just come over here
and I was
he had gotten robbed by four Asians and
got beat up that's why I took him under
my wing
I guess he was really [__] up by the
by the robbery
and uh so we went to this dude's house
and uh
man I had this this Hatchet right that I
always carried around with a sheath that
was attached to my belt
and uh in a gun a nine millimeter
uh Glock and uh I go there and I knock
on the door and I say hey uh
I know Bob called Bob
hey Bob uh I need to talk to you for
um let's say
uh Tom
's uh
we'll say Thomas the uh lone shark right
I said hey Tom said me to talk to you
real quick man
I'm like don't don't fight it dude I'll
kick in your [__] door you know and
he lets me in and he's like
he starts off like a little shaking or
anything and then he like got some balls
somehow like all of a sudden he starts
talking [__]
and he's like he's like what are you
gonna do with that gun you look like a
big old [__]
you know I'm like
I wanna I'm not a [__]
I know I'm not a [__]
and uh
yeah so I [__] told Fabian to hold
his hand and he's like what are you
gonna do [__] shoot me and I'm like
no man I'm gonna cut the finger and took
the hatchet out I cut off his [__]
Pinky
and it like cut through his whole his
whole pinky [__] flew onto the kitchen
floor and it was like halfway through
his other finger too
and I told Fabian grabbed the finger and
he threw it in the garbage disposal and
I flipped the switch and you know and I
told him 150 bucks you lost your [__]
Pinky man because you're a [__] smart
mouth you know
and it's just stupid and like he could
have died or that if I was like
even worse than what I am you know
but it went on like that you know I mean
there was a couple other ones that were
had to end in violence but most of the
time I gave people chances you know I
even let people off man you just give me
like 40 bucks you know if you owe if you
owe like a few hundred 500 or so and
I would just you know
let them off with a couple hundred bucks
and I just give the the people what they
rode and not even take it if I like them
if I thought they were sincere you know
it's all about how people respond to
people I guess you could say
you know and what is the
weapon you'll use
is it a gun or a knife or a bat or what
I always had a gun
or have you know not really anymore I
don't really do this no more
not that aspect of it but um
you could say Hatchet or uh
I have a big uh buoy knife like it looks
like a Rambo knife it's about that big
and uh it's heavy it's like five pounds
I mean it's like seriously heavy and uh
it may or it may have not cut off a
couple hands or fingers
and it's time this is Orange County or
this is La that you uh this is in
actually I've
I'll take them uh I've taken them in
Orange County LA County uh
the ones that had to go a little violent
were more out in
San Bernardino Riverside area
one of them is actually on an Indian
reservation I don't really want to talk
about that one but
that was a
yeah I mean if I look at it as if you
owe you owe I've even done collections
for uh
Bond's been our bonds bondsman or
whatever uh one Bonds company guy that I
know
uh he would give me cases and stuff
I call them cases and
I told him I'm not going to tell the
cops or anything where these people are
but I'll go get the money for you
and I go and
get the money or the collateral of the
road
one way or another
you know
that's I mean I I
caught two cases for one of the loan
sharks that I uh
that I work for I'm fighting one now so
I won't really talk about that one but
uh
another one I had he literally sent me
to go move a trailer that some dude
owned
and he told me to move it two blocks
away or a block away and that he wanted
to scare the guy so I went over there
hooked it up to my truck
moved it
and two months later I get pulled over
randomly in a city over Huntington or in
a
like Huntington Beach area but it wasn't
Huntington Beach though it was like over
there Fountain Valley or something right
and uh I think it was Fountain Valley
actually
and uh I get pulled over and I don't
know why these cops pulled me over I'm
in the truck and they're like talking to
me and I'm like I'm telling them like
yeah I mean like I'm just going uh I was
actually going to sell a firearm that I
had made
uh out of um
uh I think it's called a ram set it's
like a uh
you can buy them at Home Depot
they're like a 22 caliber gun that uh
shoots uh a nail like a hammer but it's
like a 220 caliber but I I make them
into single shot 22 caliber gun
basically with uh
without even like
doing massive work to it they're fairly
easy to turn into a single shot
and they're very very very reliable
a little a little
random of where it goes but it's usually
about a foot area of where it'll hit you
know and uh I was going to go sell it
and they didn't even catch that by the
way when they were searching my car but
anyways they were telling me right they
were like
they were like hey what are you doing
here and all of a sudden one of them
comes up with a thing I thought they
were gonna let me go and they're like
hey I just want to know one thing and he
brings up this [__] laptop I never
forget and he's like why'd you only move
the car
a block away and leave it or the trailer
right and I'm like
let me see that I look at it and the
truck looked like it was black and my
truck was blue and I'm like
that's not that's not me that my truck's
blue this one's black he's like oh hold
on he goes the next frame and it's
lighter and it's a [__] picture of me
next to my blue truck we're in the same
[__] shirt that I'm wearing at that
time two months later this red shirt
and I'm like
what the [__] can I say
because I'm caught I feel like a [__]
dumbass
and uh
Fabian was in the car with me and he has
a warrant he's going to jail for
something that he like did right when he
got here he got arrested for some
misdemeanor and
he was telling me how he needed uh to
get rid of it anyway so I guess he's
going to jail to get rid of it you know
and
I'm sitting in their awestruck that
these people this [__] cops and like
I hate cops man I got [__] cops tattooed
on my ass when they strip search me like
it literally says [__] cops on each like
one cheek is [__] four inch there's the
only one says cops and they know but
they're like bend over they know how I
feel you know and uh yeah it's [__]
cop man he was so cocky and that
[__] got me man he [__] he
was like why'd you only move it a block
away and I I had no answer all I said
was
things I I had to think of something
quick right saying I said the answer to
your questions can only be answered
if the time is right or some [__] like
that he probably thought I was a
crackhead or something man like I just
couldn't think of anything to say and
[__] yeah man they got me and I ended up
going because of my extensive background
you know uh uh criminal background man
they
they never do uh an arraignments in
County Jail
they never give you a deal the first one
right you're right I mean they never do
but I was the last one in the [__]
line that day man so they never they
never like give you a deal on your
arraignment and I've never been last in
line to go get arranged before and I've
really like like I said 14 years plus
including juvenile probably like
16 years man I'm 35 33 36 and I'm I'm
literally like
done almost
more than half about half my life in in
jail a man in prison you know
and uh
I was actually kind of freaked out about
it man because I have never been last
and
it's just some stupid misdemeanor too
man and but I didn't want to go back I
got PTSD from prison man this is not
even like
it's not even because of things I did or
seen in prison it's just the feeling of
of not having control of my situation or
my life
it it left me with night terrors of like
my mom dying or something like that
because I couldn't get a hold of her
well I was in prison this time uh
because she was in the hospital I just
lost my stepdad and it was just a really
bad
time in my life right there and uh
I ended up having night terrors still to
this day uh I'll wake up crying or some
song or something will trigger me and I
have like a full-blown panic attack and
my mom knows about it and I tell her why
I have it and uh
it's not it's really not for anything
I've done it's just I just don't want to
lose my mom you know and uh because
she's been there
but uh
yeah
I don't know what's your biggest regret
not
being there for my kids
yeah
how many kids
uh
three
I got over there now I was like on the
phone my son he was born four months
after I got busted
he was premature he was like one or one
pound six ounces he was teeny
no baby mama like had him almost four
four and a half months early
but uh
he would like
talk to me all the time on the phone
or whatever
you know
he'd always say are you happy
so God are you happy
tattoo on my head with a question mark
but yeah
what's your what's your biggest fear
at this point in your life
getting life in prison or
um
uh
losing my mom
yeah
that's what they are
those those two
I'll move my kids of course but
uh I talked to them or I see them on the
weekends and stuff even though I'm
homeless right now
you ever been homeless in my life
I go to a homeless shelter try and get a
voucher
and they kicked me out for two weeks and
I've been out for like a month and a
half now homeless on the streets
doing [__] that I don't want to do
selling drugs and
are you using yeah
yeah
uh fentanyl man
I've actually gone down from about three
grams to about a dime a day
which was
really hard to do because I was a heroin
addict I guess my that's my thing I
liked heroin and speed but speed I
already know puts me in prison I used to
shoot up like a gram of speed at a time
and
literally I've run from like my
drug dealer and business partner and and
two blocks in my boxers with a nine
millimeter because I did a gram and a
half shot and [__] I look at her and
I'm like there has to be somebody at my
house right now breaking in and she's
like what are you talking about just
[__] me and I'm like no [__] I'm gonna
go run over to my house and grab a gun
and I go run over to my apartment
[__] two blocks away she's like
driving after me like just get in the
car
I'm like there's somebody there who was
that it was it was like the last time I
shot him before I started shooting up
again not this time though I know shoot
up now
I should [__] I I did for a little
bit I actually took uh when I relapsed I
I uh it literally went from like one
Norco
one day to the next day I'm like [__]
I'm gonna shoot up some heroin so me and
my buddy of a long time were like let's
get some heroin he's like all right he's
like we can't do it after today and I'm
like don't trip dude I'm good yeah then
I did it for like a week and a half two
weeks and then all of a sudden my dealer
was like look dude you just had eight
years clean you're a drug counselor
working at rehab I'm not gonna sell it
to you anymore and I'm like bro I Gotta
Have It don't start loving me now dude
right like don't [__] love me now
dude just give me some [__] heroin
man and he's like no so that night I
went and drove over one block away from
my work at this bougie bougie rehab
center where there's a bunch of homeless
people at and I walked up to him and I
said hey man or I actually drove up to
him he was walking
I didn't want to seem like some creeper
you know oh no homophobic at all but I
like to walk up I said hey uh
[__] but do you have some uh some drugs
or do you [__] around and he's like what
do you do and I'm like black
you know heroin and he looked at me like
I said the n-word like like heroin was
like outlawed and it was like horrible
[__] he's like
Nobody Does that anymore it's fentanyl
now and I'm like what the [__] is
fentanyl because I just done like eight
years I thought it was like you touched
it you die you know
and he's like nah man I'm gonna sit here
in this car with you you're gonna take
one hit of this stuff man you're gonna
feel like you shot up a half half gram
of [__] black and I said you're a
[__] liar no friend of Jesus dude
he's like no I'm not and he [__] took
one hit
he told me he had Narcan I took one hand
I'm like you know I'm not gonna need it
I didn't need it but man
it was like
heaven
in a big warm fuzzy blanket
with every dog that I had that died
before all around me cuddling me it was
awesome and it was very stupid because
I've lost a lot of people
that I know from fentanyl before
and uh
I was gonna stay clean for my for myself
and
you know I had my brother he had just
passed from uh
from uh Huntington's disease and uh
and uh
coven actually killed him they said
but he was holding on longer than he was
supposed to when I got out and I
actually got to talk to him and make
amends with him before he died over uh
iPad
or whatever the hell it's called the
video call talk
thing and uh take some video pictures of
him and
he he could barely talk or whatever but
he uh
[__] man I'm gonna cry again
yeah Manny [__] love love him man
I feel bad [__] it up
you're trying to
cut back just to get clean there's a
goal yeah I'm I'm not even doing close
to anything I was doing
like at all like I'm very very doing
very little and I actually spaced it out
myself because I know that like it's
harder to detox from from this stuff so
like I'll go like a day and a half two
days in between using
to uh
really like wean it off you know I'm
almost done I'd say I'll be done in a
week or so
that's why I actually
came out here man
because my other brother is just got
clean and
he I need to get out of the area that I
was in so I'm out here and you know
motel hotel whatever the hell it is
but
it's cool we met some good people
already
you know I'm not I always tell everybody
I'm a Dropout you know because I don't
feel like I should
um hide it
I'm not trying to like slip and slide or
[__] like try to if I if I know
somebody I'm not going to disrespect him
by being like because I still got
respect for gang members and [__] you
know I mean weird street street respect
you know not like
like oh you're a great person but like
you know like like you know like I was
there man I respect the game whatever
you're gonna do you're gonna do man
right but it's like this I don't want
you [__] up your career criminal
career but you know your career because
you're talking to me right I want to
give you the chance to know like hey bro
I'm a drop out I'm not snitch
you know [__] weirdo you know I got
in trouble because my [__] kids are
different colors in my [__] comrades
decided they call them Spix or whatever
the [__] they want to call them right
and [__] start this issue because my
[__] kid's mom is Salvadorian you know
and uh she didn't even tell me who I
love or who I can't love you know or and
those are my kids if I'm your homeboy or
your home right you're supposed to love
me and my family you know well you call
my kids
you know speaks or whatever right I I
hate racing I'm not even I'm not even
racist man like I don't know I was a
skinhead anyways like I'm I'm I'm I'm
like uh I converted to Judaism I'm a
freaking Jew now like legit like like
dude like like I did everything I had to
do to become a Jew you know uh uh
huh for what reason
um because it's the only religion that
really makes sense to me really
uh I don't believe in Jesus I don't you
know I I uh I don't believe somebody
died for my sins like that means like
like just if like like let's go back to
child molesters basically
a child molester could touch all these
kids and all of a sudden he takes his
dude Jesus is like
um
you know uh uh this is my blood and this
is my my my body thing and like I died
for your sins nah man you [__] touch
kids you're going to hell [__]
you know you have to atone for your own
sins and that's why I I I don't I I just
believe in God
God is God not that he's come back
with some dude riding a donkey or
nothing like that man like
he's just you know it's it's it's a big
thing man like I I just can't believe in
Jesus
he just does not sit with me
right and my mom's always like you've
got to be a good Christian and I'm like
you were getting tarot card readings
last week don't talk to me about good
Christianity no I love my book but you
know we always have some bickering thing
because she loves Trump and I hate
politicians it's just whatever man it's
like all these [__] wannabe skinheads
and [__] [__] wanna love Trump
because he's like white power or
whatever the [__] man I don't even care
man I always hate politicians
no rot in hell
Anarchy
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
man that's a hard one I don't I don't
know I um
you know it's
I don't know I don't really know like
I mean like
keep it honest I try to keep it honest
as I can with everybody
but yet again I lie a lot
to people you know that I love really
it's the people I love the most I lie to
about stuff
you know
um
but they see through the [__]
anyways I can't lie my mom knows I'm
[__] lying or I'm lying and I've seen
their straight lying to her over the
phone because like I have a new gambling
addiction now that I'm [__] like I
put off Fentanyl and it's like gambling
comes up and like it's going great right
now but [__] I'm gonna lose I'm only
like 500 bucks a day basically sometimes
you know and just blowing it on [__]
buying stuff for a bunch of homeless
people where I was I'd go buy a whole
bunch of food and cook food for them and
it started to get to the point where
like I felt like I was in prison again
because like people
the white kids are like having like
disputes with each other and looking to
me for guidance and I'm like [__]
shot calling again for no [__] reason
like I'm like it happened the other day
and I'm like well if you guys are gonna
fight you gotta fight he has a [__] up
hand so make sure that you're only
fighting with one hand too
because you guys are supposed to be
[__] homeboys and I'm like what the
[__] am I doing I don't even care that
much or like about that issue like
I don't know I I honestly I have a
really good heart and I help a lot of
people out
but if you [__] over my friends or
people that I work for I don't care
unless you're a woman I don't touch
women I don't touch kids I think that
women beaters are the same thing as
[__] rapist to me
they'll never change
it's because my dad he's trying to make
amends though
he really is his last time in prison
it's because he knows he's dying
maybe not right away but
years of meth and alcohol he has
cirrhosis in the liver and
you know he's just falling apart
and
I just still don't answer the phone a
lot man it's still like he's trying so
hard man like it's like everything like
I should want but it's like
oh [__] no I'm the one not
answering the phone
you know I'm not going to be there for
all your birthdays and [__] yeah
that's what it is man
I love who I love and I don't love who I
don't
all right talk about thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah thank you
wish you lots of luck from here